so 2007 2008 you walk the Camino you
decide then you want to make the film
how did you actually get it off the
ground and get the funds over this what
five six year period to make the movie
well the initial part as soon as I
decided to make the film I reached out
to two people two women I had worked
with extensively over the years
documentary filmmakers and Cobie Atlas
and Keira Thompson Keira just won a she
is a producer
supervising producer on the voice and
Kobe was is amazing vice president of
PBS for programming used to be and now
she's doing the gazillion other things
so I reached out to them and they helped
me kind of get my footing and I had
raised I had actually raised enough
money I'd raise $60,000 for another
documentary and when I wanted to do this
one I just asked our donors if they
would be willing to let me transfer it
and then I reached out to my very first
boss Teresa to Lina Coleman and asked
her if I could run the film through her
nonprofit which is what I'd done with my
short documentary and as soon as she
heard about the the subject she was like
I want to be involved I want to work on
it
and it just so happened that she had the
exact same amount of money that she
needed to invest into a film because
it's a non-profit so it needed to be
kind of recirculated and so we had just
enough for a super bare-bones shoot I
mean it was we were paying people $100 a
day
but luckily since I'd worked in the film
industry most of my life people were I
could get great people and they were
doing it as a favor to me and so we
actually did run out of money on the
shoot and I had to put in some of my own
life savings just a bit but some and
then afterwards we came back we cut
together this 23 minute fundraising
trailer and you know I knew it wouldn't
be easy but I thought okay you know
we'll apply to some foundations and some
religious Institute organization
and government institutions and you know
Spanish tourism and all these places but
of course that was right when the crash
happened and Spain was just a mess I
mean there was just no money there
whatsoever and we got turned down right
left and center all the traditional
funding sources except for one grant we
got from Pacific pioneer fund and then
we did we also got two small grants from
American pilgrims but then everything
else was all raised from individuals and
I what happened was after about a year
and a half of trying the traditional
funding I realized I wasn't it wasn't
gonna happen that way and I it pretty
much turned into me asking everyone I'd
ever met or knew for money and here was
a case though I really had to kind of do
some work around my issues with money
and asking for money and asking for help
and what was really neat and really
extremely touching was my high school
classmates really turned out and it was
they funded almost 40% of the posts of
that phase of once I needed to finish
the film and incredibly supportive
people I hadn't seen in 30 years sending
in thousand-dollar checks and and then I
had four out of five of my funding
producers I had gone to high school with
and I was also really the one of my
classmates is Dan Brown who did the da
Vinci Code and he and his wife stepped
in and funded the whole online process
once they saw the rough cut and they
were just really touched and believed in
the project and if it wasn't for Dan and
Blythe I might still be fundraising
advice to other filmmakers on doing the
same not only just getting over the
hurdle of having to ask for help which
is a big thing we all you know DIY we
want to do this ourselves no we don't
need
anyone's help but ways to do it ways to
get over yeah um there was a couple of
books I really recommend I think kind of
working on your internal stuff with with
money is the first step I think pretty
much everything we do really is from
from the inside out there's a book
called spiritual economics by Eric
Butterworth the power the soul of money
by Lynne twist and then Lynne twist also
has a CD set fundraising from the heart
and I think that the the biggest thing I
would encourage people is only do things
that you're a hundred and ten percent
believe are gonna do some good in the
world there has to be something fueling
you more than money more than fame like
some really inherits strong pull for you
because it's just too hard otherwise I
mean to sustain it I think so was there
a moment where you felt burnout where
you felt like my back skins well I don't
know how I can continue and then how did
you pull yourself up there were many
many many many many moments it's been a
constant constantly falling down and
getting back up I mean each phase has
had these huge you know I I thought for
sure I was going to get this grant and
the executive director from the Catholic
media campaign and and I thought for
sure it was gonna happen and it was like
no again and I I did have I had a little
ritual and I still do to a degree this
day when I'm going through a rough time
when I get a big disappointment I really
allow myself to feel it I a lot of times
it involves the fetal position and a lot
of Tears and then it's like I go to a
movie
I get popcorn and I cry and then I get
up the next day and start again and it's
pretty I wouldn't say it's constant but
it's it doesn't stop I mean as as
successful as the film has been we still
keep having so many challenges and
financially we're still we're just
getting by
just because everything is so expensive
but I think it's my I think the biggest
thing I would say is not denying the
pain or the frustration or the
disappointment and simultaneously not
wallowing in it letting yourself have
that and for me having a ritual around
it of like okay another rejection I'm
gonna go to my movie I'm gonna do this
and then I'm gonna start again
you